alaba namens luca und herzlich
willkommen ja heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal in dem wir uns hält martin
anschauen werden ich würde heute sagen
wir fackeln gar nicht lange rum und
fangen direkt an mit der ersten marke
und zwar kennt sie jeder
jeder hat schon mal chips von ihnen
gegessen und zwar sind es die bringe ich
war allerdings jetzt mal ein bisschen im
internet unterwegs und habe dabei diese
[Musik]
kommt bei den aus dort aber wo wir
gerade schon mal fake marken sind es ist
natürlich auch irgendwo das thema des
heutigen videos jeder von euch kennen
glaube ich kitkat also diese
schokoriegel mit bisschen keks drin wo
zwei in einer verpackung sind zumindest
in länglichen kann man so auseinander
brechen also kennen glaube ich jeder hm
ich habe allerdings eine fake marke
gefunden namens kate code können wir
noch denken dass das katzenkot ist helfe
break have acat code ja jeder von euch
kennt wahrscheinlich half also dieses
große grüne monster das unter anderem in
dem film the avengers mitspielt
da gibt es allerdings diese fake marke
von es heißt nicht erwünscht sondern
rangers und er heißt noch nicht halt
sondern mit incredible feller das hier
ist die nächste feldmark und auf den
ersten blick denkt man nicht
wahrscheinlich - so alles richtig aber
es heißt halt nicht darf sondern dave ja
ich benutze auch immer dave um mich
einzucremen
die nächste sache das sind direkt drei
sachen komplett falsch eigentlich heißt
die figur elmo aus der sesamstraße bei
dieser fake marke heißt es allerdings
erst mal sesam 'street also sehr
mühsames straße die person heißt nicht
elmo sondern elbow und die haben sogar
das alphabet buchstaben nichts anderes
als klatschen durch mein zimmer zu
laufen dass hier soll glaube ich mario
sein
die haben den fake aber einfach
videogame guy genannt also dafür kriegt
ihr von mir auf jeden fall den ruin der
woche jeder fröhlichkeit wahrscheinlich
die market in north face machen
hauptsächlich jacken regen jagten
winterjacken et cetera ppm die feldmark
von von north face heißt allerdings
youtube machen da drauf die allerdings
gerade schon bei klamotten marken sind
im ihr werdet wahrscheinlich auch nike
kennen
hier heißt es mike und wo wir schon
gerade bei nike beziehungsweise auch
sportklamotten sind eben jeder von euch
kennt selbst wahrscheinlich auch adidas
hier heißt es sei da und hat vier
streifen am liebsten würde ich mir
tausendmal gegen das gesicht schlag
werde ich so etwas sehe einige ältere
zuschauer unter euch werden
wahrscheinlich noch den gameboy kennen
das war also der vorreiter vom nintendo
ds et cetera pp obwohl mittlerweile die
meisten er glaube ich sogar place oder
auf dem handy
zocken der fake vom camp den ich raus
und allerdings games scheint aber
eigentlich ist es gar nicht so blöd weil
gameboy spricht eigentlich nur die jungs
allerdings würde ich sagen machen wir
direkt weiter mit der nächsten feld
marke und zwar werden sehr viele von
euch die marke mountain you can die
machen getränke und die fake marke von
mountain view heißt mountain view und
einfach ein blick auf heidelberg es tut
mir leid dass ich nur abklatschen aber
doch einfach wirklich nicht mehr zu
sagen auf den allerersten blick sieht
das hier so aus wie so eine typische
lego star wars verpackung das heißt
allerdings nicht lego sondern do it
yourself robot blog und das heißt noch
nicht star wars sondern universe
auf sonnenschein beginnen hat mir eine
fake marke von hulk beziehungsweise den
avengers und ich würde sagen wir bleiben
direkt bei den avengers denn das hier
ist natürlich super wenn er hier
allerdings special
menschenrechte sind ziemlich abstoßend
dass er erkennt glaube ich jeder direkt
und zwar ist das eine maske von sonic
hier heißt es allerdings nicht sonnig
sondern blue speedway wen wen wollt also
wirklich wen wollt ihr verarschen kommen
allerdings nur noch schon meine damen
und herren zum letzten feld marke die
hier für das heutige video hier raus
gesucht habe und zwar ist es ein
controller der auf den ersten blick
völlig normal aussieht allerdings nicht
von sony ist sondern von sony er kostet
auch nur fünf euro 50 und auf den
knöpfen rechts steht auch helfer vor nie
drauf los sind wenn ich so die wehr
alter ich wäre richtig mit anders sah
das heutige video seite ist auch beenden
meine lieben freunde ich habe letztens
ein bass wie artikel gesehen wo diese
ganzen feld marken vorgestellt wurde ich
habe einfach gedacht hey du ja das kann
doch vorne und hinten nicht wahr sein
der link zu diesem artikel befindet sich
auf jeden fall und in der beschreibung
lässt einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video hier darf als solch gefallen hat
und abonniert main kanal falls sie noch
kein teil der lose alt
[Musik]